you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career
you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions it's the ramsay show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
dr john dolone best-selling author
ramsey personality and host of the dr
john dolone show is my co-host today
with a brand new book out own your past
change your future and it is in rocket
ship mode it is selling like crazy for
those of you haven't gotten a copy you
are one of the few tens of thousands of
folks have bought the co bought the book
in the last week and we appreciate that
thank you very very much we'll be taking
your calls today about your money about
doing work that you love about creating
real
relationships open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five ryan is going to start off
this hour in oklahoma city hi ryan how
are you
wonderful how are you dave better than i
deserve what's up
well uh
i'll just give you the the quick part of
it uh my wife and i are in baby steps
four five and six
uh we are uh about to receive a an early
inheritance we'll say my parents are
giving my brother and i the farm
um and basically my brother's going to
buy me out so my
my portion of that would be about 400
dollars wow um
well it's it's uh it's a very generous
gift that my parents are blessing us
with and so
um what my question is is uh we our our
mortgage that's left is about 275 000
which in any normal case
i actually uh teach uh partnership
police university our class so as i
would instruct any of our other folks i
would say pay off your mortgage but we
have a potential impending move back to
texas in the next year or two possible
and so
my question became do i go ahead and pay
off the mortgage
um and sit you know sit on the the
balance to potentially
buy a house uh where we're going down in
texas
or
uh do i go ahead and sit on all of it uh
to pay cash for a house down in texas
and then sell the house here
okay well um yeah i'd go ahead and pay
it off
and uh then when you get remove the
texas you're going to have the cash in
your hand because you're going to sell
the house
so all the money you put in the house is
going to come back out
okay so you don't lose the money
obviously when you pay it off it's just
invested into the house
and so um because you're going to sell
the house you'll so you'll have all this
money plus whatever's left over all the
house the paid for house money and the
money that's left over from the
inheritance all for
the the advance inheritance all for um
the texas property the per the
the cash purchase down there yes yes
that's definitely what i would do
definitely what i would do okay
wonderful mom and dad got mom and dad
got good tax advice right
yes sir uh and they my brother has been
looking for uh property outside of town
and uh
uh they have decided during the early
70s they've decided they need to move
into town so it was a win-win for
everybody and they they're transferring
this with
good tax advice so they don't get a
a gift tax problem yes sir they they
they are doing a gift tax return through
the unified gift state uh yes that's
exactly what they're doing yes they're
good and you get to leave oklahoma and
go to texas everybody's winning here
everybody
everybody's winning
everybody they get to go back get to go
back to texas yes we do are they in
texas
they are they're down in central texas
very smackdown
oh my gosh have you got kids
i do yes small price to pay to get the
grandkids close that's right it is and
that's the that's the other portion of
getting back to texas is
getting them uh back close to family as
as my parents health is not great it's
not terrible but it's not great so
get back closer to where we can see them
on a regular basis that's a beautiful
beautiful story your mom and dad have
been not only generous but everybody's
gonna win on this it's all the way
around it's very very good cool
love it man congratulations yeah go
ahead and pay off the house in oklahoma
because you can sell it when you get
ready to leave and they'll give you a
check at the closing and you can use
that check plus whatever's left over to
buy your next property no problem oh
janelle's in toledo hi janelle how are
you
hi great thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
my question for you
i'm really starting to get serious i
only have fifteen hundred dollars of
debt to pay off before i'm done good
um my question i want to start saving
for my next car
and i also want to start saving for a
mortgage
my question is
should i build two separate accounts for
these and should they be money market or
savings uh it doesn't matter they're
about the same thing
money market or savings doesn't matter
much and of course you're gonna build an
emergency fund for you do either one of
these right
correct maybe step three you're gonna
finish your emergency fund okay
now i personally and it's okay to do it
either way but i personally would choose
to move up in car i'm guessing you're
driving a beater
i'm not actually
kind of interesting
what are you driving why do you want to
change cars
well i don't want to change right now
i'm just thinking for future i
do not want to change any time what are
you driving i'm thinking
a buick verano 2012
it's been paid for i paid cash for it it
was my parents
okay what i was leading what i was
leading to is
i have found with a lot of things in
this life but certainly money is one of
them
that what you focus on is what happens
and when you disperse your focus across
two things it frustrates the crud out of
me on both things i'd rather just knock
one out and then go knock the next one
out and i would just choose one of the
other
and so in other words i would just go
i'm gonna i'm gonna drive the buick
until i get my down payment
and then when i get my house i'm gonna
save up and buy a better car
or vice versa
i mean you can do both at the same time
it's not illegal it's not against quote
the ramsey plan
but the power of focus is something i
can't do it i i have to laser in on one
thing and knock it out otherwise i get
just become a scattered mess and when i
get frustrated
i kind of
i'm a guy that like i'll be eating well
eating well have chips and queso one
night and i'm like oh this thing's over
right and the next thing i know i'm
gonna cover donut dust and whatever else
right and so like i have to focus in on
one thing and just
that's so very lazy
it's not it's not a pretty with the
gummy bear spots all over all over the
place i think my wife's got some pretty
damning photos somewhere
but no i can get off the rails but i got
to stay focused that way yeah john
deloney cancel culture comes out with
your wife's
photos with gummy bears oh it's stuck to
my face yeah gummy bear spots and uh
powdered doughnuts and there that just
ruins the whole mental health game i'm
out that's right
i'm out
but i think you're right we try to do
everything all at the same time man yeah
it's hard to do and that's one of the
reasons the baby steps work yep the
clear plan is do this don't do anything
else and then do this don't do anything
else
and and there's something about that
power of focus that that it locks your
brain in it locks your habit patterns in
and anything that's not aligned with
that one thing then you don't do it well
people do that with their marriages like
they want to have a kid and also we want
to save for this we want to buy this we
want to fix our intimacy issues we want
to go to grad school it's like dude
we want to hike through europe yeah slow
down man
slow down one thing at a time pick one
pick one
yeah it's okay to do both it's not the
end of the world but that's just some
commentary
on it that uh from a couple of guys who
struggle with with having our attention
on one thing at a time
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america dr john
dolone ramsey personality is my co-host
today he will be in dallas this coming
week and uh part of that will be a book
signing wednesday night
at uh barnes and noble and that's over
there on uh
beltline road that one yeah so be sure
and get ready for that it's gonna happen
coming up soon where in the world is
that well i guess it's not here okay but
anyway and also guys we are getting
ready to hit the road with our building
wealth live event we're so excited to be
back out again all of us are going or
most all of us
will be in las vegas and orlando this
spring las vegas is next thursday one
week from this thursday may the 5th
there's still a few tickets available
now this is all about uh investing real
investing how to really build wealth
it's me rachel cruz george campbell
we're also bringing dr john dolone king
coleman along and we're gonna have some
wonderful panels there we'll all be
signing books doing photos taking uh
taking the city by storm las vegas may
the 5th then in a couple of weeks after
that orlando may the 19th
then sacramento is in the fall november
the 1st minneapolis november the 10th
and san antonio november the 15th
warning
all of these events are approaching a
sellout especially
orlando's getting very very close and
the ones in the fall are dangerously
close
tickets are only twenty five dollars and
you can get a four pack
for only sixty dollars so you know bring
a couple of your friends with you
60 bucks for four people that's a deal
check it out at ramseysolutions.com
events hit the live events page there
come out and hang out with us and uh
make it part of the program open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five john's in
new york city hi john welcome to the
ramsay show
hi dave thanks for having me on uh how
are you better than i deserve what's up
that's what i wanted to hear
i'm uh i'm better than i deserve also um
i wanted to start with a thank you
uh i went to fpu a number of years ago
and
my wife and i are currently on four five
and six
and uh i looked down a few months ago
and realized that we're uh babysit
millionaires way to go
thank you i just finished listening to
baby steps millionaires so thank you for
that one um
and so
and i'm right now i'm re-listening to
tmmo
and uh
you know there was there was something
that you said about you know how once
you finished roughly baby step three
if you're in a job you don't like you
know you should start looking for
something
that is more in line with what god put
you here to do
and i've really struggled over the last
i don't know probably 10 years or more
over
what that is and i kind of ask because
you know i i i always kind of get this
feeling of
um i've been a cosmetic chemist for two
decades
and it's like
did god really put me here to make
shampoo in motion and by the way i'm a
i'm also a fat bald guy
[Laughter]
and so i was you know i've even spoken
to ken coleman about this a couple of
years ago and
um
yeah i was just wondering if you had any
insight for figuring out what what
you're supposed to do i will say i've
had this long feeling lately that i need
to go teach an fpu class at my church
but
my
a couple of things
one is the way that
calling gets talked about purpose gets
talked about especially in a faith
context
is that god somehow has hidden something
from you and you've got to spend your
life trying to go find out where he hid
it like what's god's purpose in
i i i don't love that um that way of
looking at it
what i really love is what are the sets
of skills and talents and experiences
you've had plus
all of us have an inner i just call it
an inner gnawing
um that
that gently nudges sometimes i've been
two hands shoved right into a direction
so i would ask you
not so much what do you want to run from
right you may have been making lotions
for two decades and you're kind of like
ah
what do you
what do you when you imagine what that
would be what what is it
is it teaching is it something is it
singing song like what is it
so it's actually funny like you know
from a from a skill set and a and uh
what am i good at like you know being a
cosmetic chemist is is it like i i teach
a master's class
in a cosmetic chemistry program
um you know i'm actually on my way to
teach class in about three hours
um
and so like it really comes easy to me
and and
if i look back
um
i could only say that god pushed me into
it it was
you know i was i was in
newspaper printing
the god awful industry for about a year
let me ask you this when you're teaching
the class
on chemistry
how does that feel
i i don't i don't
i don't find in your words that i have
the heart of a teacher now i might then
why then why are you getting a nudge to
why are you knowing to teach financial
peace university
that i i think is
is sort of
feeling like
an obligation
um like i've gotten i i've gotten so
much out of out of here so you just want
to that's again that's i want to give i
want to return i want to pay it forward
on something that blessed me i
appreciate that that's kind of but that
doesn't matter that doesn't inform your
question so john can i challenge you on
something
please
i think you want to feel significant
and i think you like
when you're teaching even though you
don't like having the heart of a teacher
you do like having students who say this
guy provides value and somehow you have
convinced yourself
that
making
cosmetics is not um that it provides no
value
well i i'll admit that it's sort of how
i feel it's sort of a it's like is this
it
imagine this
you're supposed to be making shampoo
that's a common life question that that
is less related to calling a purpose and
more like there's just some life stages
this is what this is i have a friend
john that's a um
a world-class commercial photographer
a known name
in that world big he's a big deal
but one of the things he does
on uh
on the side so to speak is a ministry
is he will go to the ladies homeless
shelter
with makeup artists and hair
people and do glamour shots
for these ladies who have lost their
identity to homelessness
and uh and it just lights up his whole
world he
he he it's an incredible incredible idea
to start with this very fun idea what
he's doing is beautiful but it just that
occurs to me with what you're doing that
somehow there's a piece of what you're
doing that could be done for someone
that might not have access to
uh what your company provides but maybe
you could do something without violating
any kind of employment agreement or
anything that provided uh what you do to
uh the someone who might not have access
to it like in this case the guy's going
into ladies homeless shelter but that's
uh an idea that pops into my head so
what you're looking for is uh a friend
of mine used to say gather your bouquet
of flowers from those that are within
reach
it's not a mystery
they're all right there in front of you
and so go take ken coleman's assessment
if you haven't i'll have kelly pick up
and give it to you
and um
and continue to do that and i always
love the lion and chariots of fire i
feel god's pleasure when i run
is what eric whatever his name was said
the real guy that was the movie was made
about but he said when i'm running
i feel god's pleasure
and because someone was questioning why
he didn't stop racing and going to the
ministry
and he said because when i run
i feel god's pleasure and that's what
you're looking for and by the way you
don't feel it 24 7. no there's some
times that you're going through tsa and
the stupid delta changes the flight
because delta is greek for you ain't
getting there
and
you know you don't feel god's pleasure
because you're on the way to wherever to
go speak right
but when you get up there to do the
thing
even though you're tired
the wind is at your back
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
open phones this hour dr john deloney
ramsey personality is
my co-host
michael and kathleen
are in atlanta georgia says on my screen
you guys are debt-free congratulations
thank you thank you way to go how much
did you guys pay off
[Music]
uh we paid off 260 000
wow how long did that take about 30
months
good and your range of income during
that time
uh we started at 170k
and today we are up to 290. wow
what do you guys do for a living
i'll go first so i work in software
and my wife i work in legal technology
for a law firm
oh so both of you chose these uh
underpaying careers bless your hearts
so proud of y'all you're killing it what
kind of debt was this 260
it was the house you paid off the house
i'm talking to weird people
how old are you guys
uh i am 51 and
47. all right very good way to go what's
this house worth
uh right about now we're at right at
800k wow
way to go you guys how much is in your
401ks and iras
oh boy
800
between all of them put together so
you're debt free housing to everything
baby steps millionaires
yup way to go you did that about a year
and a half ago absolutely and you're 50
years old you rock uh-huh it's
absolutely perfect absolutely incredible
i'm so proud of you very cool so what
was the final thing that happened
because you guys were already on this
path but something happened to two and a
half years ago flipped the old switch
for you
well so actually the whole journey
started about um six years ago
with my husband listening to this guy
named dave ramsey and reading total
money makeover
and
coming to me after we'd paid off all of
our consumer debt and cut up our credit
cards and said i think we could pay the
house off
and so we started the process and
um about two months before that house
was paid off not this house
we decided to sell it and start all over
again well why not
why not
so then we start again about two and a
half years ago we were like okay back
kick back into gear and started all over
again with you know and we've always
been you know over these last few years
the monthly budget meetings which
um i'm not gonna lie i was harder to
come around than my husband was and we
had some interesting budget meetings but
they're a lot better now
what does that mean
interesting budget you had some big
fights tell us about them
yes i i you know i'm i'm not the
financial person i am better now um but
uh it was difficult for me but my
husband god bless his soul was patient
and made it work and you work with
lawyers which meant you you came armed
huh
yeah yeah i argue by nature
i love it that's so good okay so
uh that's nice that you pay him that
compliment but you also had some things
you added to the equation with these
arguments right
like we have to have a life while we're
doing this
a hundred percent that was that was
exactly right i'm gonna let him take it
from there
i i think i think we had a lot of good
conversations that's how i like to think
about it
i tell you one thing we did i think dave
you mentioned it earlier on that's the
way i choose you're doing some check-ins
you know throughout the month
and i think that was helpful too for us
yeah you gotta not just set the budget
and run it you've got to set it and
check in
and constantly make the little tweaks
and adjustments that life that life
absolutely
way to go you guys i'm very very proud
of you okay you're big time
you're 50 years old your baby steps
millionaires you even went and bought
another house and paid it off i mean all
within the guidelines of what we teach
everything is right there you did you
you know nothing you said you know it's
something i wouldn't have recommended
had you called here on the air
everything fit um and now you're there
not only you know you're worth a couple
million dollars
paid for house so you're actually
experts uh you're not somebody with just
an opinion you've actually got an
experience
what is the key
to getting out of debt and building
wealth
oh my god i mean it was a budget and
it's just being on the same page and
even having those you know healthy
discussions
even through any arguments or anything
like that just at the end of the day
agreed to do it together
yeah
that's powerful
yeah that's the that's the art of being
married really
does that to you yeah i mean it's uh
learning to uh to be wrong or to be
right and still go along
kathleen what would you advise would you
give a couple right now
one of them is
just bent on keeping spinning and not
doing that budget at some point you said
all right i'm going to submit to this
process
what advice would you give him
you know it was
it was the goals that he showed me that
what we can accomplish and what
retirement would look like and that had
been one of the things that i've always
wanted to do is to try and retire early
and for us to enjoy our lives earlier
than later and and so i guess that was
sort of the carrot and the stick that he
gave to me was you know we can do this
if we do x y and z
and it was just a good constant healthy
discussion and he also did and we also
built in
you know vacations we lived and we still
you know we
we were lucky enough that we already we
didn't have any consumer debt at the
time and we
um were able to just focus on knocking
this out and still living i mean we live
skinny but not
not quite leaving right but yeah more
like you know chicken and beans and rice
so what um man that's powerful
oh man that's so good
yeah cause we hear a lot of guys who
come at you with you need to sell this
and sell this but he came at her with a
picture right yeah this is what this can
look like yeah you gotta you gotta this
is a bigger deal so you live like no one
else now you're ready to live and give
like no one else what's your big thing
you want to do right now that you're
going to enjoy you said we can enjoy our
money so what's the what's the big
enjoyment what's the next big thing
gosh i don't know um
yeah
we're gonna give ourselves sort of a
celebratory trip at the end of the year
where are you going but i think most
mostly it is like increasing that budget
amount for what we can give yeah where
are you going on the trip do you know i
think it might be antique
we're thinking about that that's sweet
that's a good trip you ought to do that
one i like that one yeah very very good
st lucia's not bad either yeah good good
for you guys well done well done
i love it i'm so proud of you we got a
copy of the baby steps millionaires for
you since you are one how ordinary
people build extraordinary wealth how
you can too maybe you can read it and
then give it away you never know this is
what i did right here and also got a
copy a total money makeover because
that's what you did you can give that
away as well so proud of you guys your
heroes congratulations baby steps
millionaires debt-free house and
everything
they're weirdos
michael and kathleen atlanta georgia 260
000 paid off in 30 months making 170 to
290. count it down let's hear a debt
free scream
three two
one
[Music]
[Applause]
well done
well done
well they were a little early on some of
their numbers our exact typical
millionaire statistically in the 10 000
millioners that we studied was 51 years
old when they became a millionaire their
house had been paid for a while
and um
one third of them
make less than a hundred thousand
dollars
now these guys make more than a hundred
thousand dollars considerably but they
got two million dollars by the time they
were 50 not 1 million right and uh and
they did it paying off the house here at
the end of the run and that's a perfect
thing so so they really they were
probably millionaires early
and uh that's how they get to 2 million
by the time they got to 51 the classic
number is that 51 year old
that's the uh that's the case study the
the statistical average the statistical
mean
i keep going back to that most common
question we get is how do i get my
spouse on board and we always land back
there paying them a picture of what this
looks like what this is
live like no one else so that later you
can live and give like no one else don't
start with the start of that center
start with the backup yeah
this is the ramsey shot
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
825-5225 dan's in kansas city hi dan
welcome to the ramsey show
well uh dave um
i am in a quandary okay uh
my wife and i married each other um
that's always a good thing to do
[Laughter]
excellent excellent yes yes
thank you very much
uh we got married uh it'll be two years
in july
um
since then we've been looking for a home
here and these prices have just gotten
insane
um
and
what we're having a major disagreement
about
and i mean a major disagreement about is
how to pay for this
i
uh
she said that when we got married this
is a conversation that
i don't remember all the particular
details but she said that our original
plan was that she met or sells her house
i sell mine of which i already have and
i moved in with her in her place which
already has a hundred thousand dollars
worth of debt i married a hundred
thousand dollars worth of debt too
uh so
so she also says that we agreed when
before we got married that i would sell
my
farm property
which is a quarter section out in
western kansas
um
that's been in family hands for 130
years now i don't exactly remember that
part of the conversation
but
i know that
when we sell that it's going to involve
capital gains taxes pretty substantial
ones my accountant says somewhere
between
oh 40 to 50 000
combined federal and state
so i propose to my wife this
that we keep the property
still buy a house because we can
we can cash flow
with the wheat sales about another five
six hundred dollars worth of payments
above and beyond of what we do now
then we take the milo money
and we bank that for the next five years
which is when i plan to retire
and then we'll have at least that money
to pay most if not all
of these capital gains taxes
and then
we sell the property at that point and
retire the mortgage she says no sell it
now
and
you know then buy something cash
what do you think
so i'm hearing that either way the
property is sold it's just a matter of
now or five years from now
well
unless we can find a way or buy a
property that we can that we can because
she said let's stop a second
because
yeah this property you know you outlined
a very emotional
thing that's been in your family for 130
some odd years
130 yeah yeah so
you know um
all
math aside
and even marital arguments aside
um
are you
gonna sell this property
ever
well at some point because she has no
children and i have no children we've
never been married before and we have no
family
uh really i know that enters into it
yeah i mean well
it's going to leave the family you're
saying it's going to leave the family
when you die anyway
yes okay yeah so why not go ahead and
enjoy
the fruits of some of it now what's it
worth if you sold it now
around 300. okay
all right and what's wrong with your
wife's current house as a place for
y'all just to stay
well
it's
it's a it's a two-bedroom townhouse
and um
and has one bath and and i've shared
i love my wife dearly that i've shared a
bath with her for almost two years and
i've not enjoyed the process okay so uh
so you guys what's the town house worth
that penthouse is worth about 180 190
and with her um
with all the when we've had our
what is anything owed on it 100 thousand
on it about a hundred thousand yeah okay
and so it's going to clear about 80 and
you got about 300 over there and if you
got money left over from the sale of
your house also
110. okay
all right and so
you could buy a 200 000 property and pay
cash for it
well we could but you can't get
really much in kansas city particularly
in johnson county where we live
you can't get much
for 200 let me flip this around what's
the alternative
you've created this what i would say is
a highly complex and i moved here from a
farming community a complex the the
grains have to hit has to rain right
we've got to get the subsidy in you've
laid out a complex matrix for five years
from now we could x y and z
yeah
that's some gymnastics life's a lot
simpler just know it now yeah
and a capital gain sounds like a
distraction to me
if if i didn't have all this other stuff
in this conversation i would tell you to
sell the property now pay the capital
gains sell the townhouse
and go buy a property that both of you
love now what's bothering me about that
is
that the two of you after two years
can't to two old dogs
trying to learn new tricks working
together is tougher
than two young pups doing that and so
um i i'm a whole lot i'm 90 concerned in
this conversation about the fact that
you two can't resolve this argument and
i'm only 10 concerned with how you
resolve it
yeah um
i mean to the point that she's even
saying you said things you don't
remember saying
that's weird
well um
she's a pretty powerful personality and
there are times
during our long relationship dating and
married
that i have found it um
more
and i might have agreed to that i don't
i remember you what you're saying is you
caved
well i have found
that that sometimes it's better
or at least in the short term it's
better today
than to
keep
keep trying to re resolve the issue okay
that's my problem
okay
john help me here yes
my problem is i don't give a rip if you
sell the farm or not but the problem is
if you sell the farm and go do exactly
what she wants this is going to come up
again or if you lie to her in order to
get through a conversation all you're
doing is kicking the can down the road
for a larger explosion when it happens
and now you've drawn lines and the part
that you you've drawn battle lines i've
got my plan well she's got her plan
and
man this just doesn't end well it ends
unnecessarily bad particularly if both
of your plans end up with sell on the
farm
and so i would love to see you circle
back to her and say all right
so i've never done this before i've
never had a little marital spat like
this before with 130 year old property
i'm asking for a
mulligan can we start the conversation
anew
what do we want to look at you're
talking about she brought into debt and
i'm married y'all are all on the same
page you're just having to practice
doing life together after a long time of
not having to do life together expect
there to be stumbles be curious about
them don't get angry and frustrated
about them and always circle back and
say hey we need to do this one over
again and this is one you'll need to do
over again because what you're fighting
about is do we want to have a pretty
nice house for the rest of our life just
to ride or die with until this thing's
over which could be a lot of fun but if
you get bogged up in the mechanics of
how we're going to get there man then
you're just going to get
i caved and she held me to it
and i sold 130 130 year old family
property when i didn't want to just to
make her happy in this house then the
first time she whines about the
wallpaper you're going to go bananas
you're going to burn the house down out
of spite i might know somebody that did
this so i'm just telling you okay
i i'm i've got this friend right so this
buddy named rave damsey
[Laughter]
yeah so you guys need to work on the
relationship part of this and then the
actual mechanics of how to do the deal
will be a whole lot easier
that's what's scaring john and i we're
looking at each other while you're
telling all this this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's john delony co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
this is where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
amazing incredible real relationships dr
john dolone ramsey personality
best-selling author is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about
building wealth doing the work you love
and creating real relationships open
phones triple eight eight two five
five two two five is the number courtney
starts off this hour in baltimore hi
courtney welcome to the ramsey show
hi happy monday thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
um so i'm recently divorced um and i
have about which is the very thing and
have about 60k in debt that i'm
struggling to tackle i've struggled the
process um i started the process of
doing a cash out refinance with my home
since it has a ton of equity
but since my credit score is pretty low
i'm going through a broker and not a
traditional lender
so my monthly payment will be
increasing
and my interest rate will be higher so
i'm starting to rethink my decision
um but other than selling my home
uh which i really don't want to do i'm
not sure what other options i may have
to be able to get myself back in a
better financial situation how long have
you been divorced
um almost a year now so last august
everything was finalized
children
um yes one three-year-old
all right
and um what do you make a year
um about 100 101.
okay
and what's the house worth
um
its recent appraisal was for 4 30. um i
purchased it for 150.
you purchased it
yes well no i have my current mortgage
it's we
purchased it
you bought it with your ex right
no i purchased my home before i was
married oh okay and so you got the home
after okay so you owe 150
and you owe 60 and you make a hundred
yes
okay
all right
um well i i'm really glad that you gave
this second thoughts because it was a
mistake to refinance this yeah don't do
it don't do it don't do it yeah you're
getting ready to make an error and the
reason you're getting ready to make an
error was you're solving a short-term
problem with a long-term solution
and
and a bad one at that because you're
getting a higher interest rate and a
payment you can't afford and all that
kind of stuff so what do you owe the
sixty thousand dollars on
um credit cards
okay
um and when has that popped up
um so there are credit cards that i
have had for about five years now
um
and
you've had this debt sixty thousand
dollars in for five years
um so i actually opened the account
within the last five years okay when did
you run up the debt
about five years ago
okay before the development
yes okay how much debt have you run up
lately
um
none uh because i don't have any
additional credit to try to run up
okay
let's just take minimum payments with my
um
with my piece
how long were you married
uh about two years what do you do for a
living
i'm a public health researcher
would you believe us if we told you
that
with about 18 months of grinding it you
could be done maybe 24 months
um it's hard to believe but if if you
think that's an option i can
mathematically it's an option okay okay
i mean i i i i can can i be mean for a
second
sure you got the same barrier that i've
got and that john has
the thing that's going to keep you from
doing it's the person in your mirror
yeah not the math you make a hundred
thousand dollars a year you got a
reasonably low house payment um
and
you've treated this credit card debt
like it's cute
like it was something you swept under
the rug and didn't deal with it
emotionally
and you're hurting after a divorce even
though you called it a good thing it
still hurts
i'm guessing that's the father of your
child
and i'm guessing that i'm guessing that
it hurts
and um
you know so this is the time where you
say okay i'm going to be like a grown
woman instead of a little girl and i'm
going to get
roll up my sleeves and attack this stuff
as a part of my healing and as a part of
my going forward in this future i've got
to get control of this part of me that
was out of control and you actually said
the only reason you're not running up
more debt is just because they won't let
you
right not because you got under got
yourself under control
so i think you have a beautiful life
lesson to get you under control and
learn to trust you to not overspend
as you work your way out of this so this
tough 18 months on beans and rice and
you're not going to see the inside of a
restaurant unless you're working there
working extra
selling everything in sight we're going
to be on a budget we're going to be on a
budget we're going to tell our money
what to do if you will do all of that we
can show you how to pay this off in 18
months it's only 30 000 a year for two
years and you make a hundred
okay and you're done and then you don't
have to look and go gosh the only reason
i didn't run up debt is because they
wouldn't let me you go the reason i
don't run up debt is is stupid and i'm
not a person that does that anymore i
used to be that person
and courtney one of the most common
things i hear from folks who just got
divorced is
uh whether even when like you said it's
a quote unquote good thing
is you lose that trust in yourself
right i thought it was going to look
like this i
thought this person was going to be like
this right
and if you will commit to 18 months of
grinding and out
you're getting after it you will find
yourself standing taller you're gonna
get your confidence find new muscles
that you don't have you will be like
yeah dude listen look at you'll be i'm a
warrior princess leave me alone exactly
and you know what else is cool that
three-year-old little girl is going to
get to watch you too
she's going to feel it in the other way
oh little boy that little boy is going
to watch his mama he's going to feel it
in the air his the air will change in
your house while you're fighting through
this does all that
ring true to your heart right now
it does okay definitely not
what i thought you were going to say but
i think that's what i need to see here
i think i think you have a huge
opportunity to fix you and the byproduct
is going to be the 60 000 goes away in
the process
okay it'll evaporate you learn to handle
this stuff in a grown-up way and you
throw your shoulders back and go yeah
baby game on
right and anytime money stuff comes at
you then
you're in control of it it's not in
control of you for the rest of your life
and that's how people end up becoming
wealthy by the way we're gonna do we're
gonna take care of this for you we're
gonna show you exactly what to do we've
got a nine week class called financial
peace university i'm gonna sign you up
for that in ramsey plus for free i'm not
gonna charge you a dime for it because i
think you're a hero getting ready to
happen and i wanna be part of the story
okay great thank you so much hey you
promised you'll do it
i've already put it okay put on hold on
the second is yes i'm taking it the
answer is the answer is she's going to
do it
and we're going to show you exactly what
to do in ramsey plus at financial peace
university with the every dollar app all
completely is our gift to you you're
you're ready you're the kind of person
and i'm really glad that that they you
know you didn't get that alone oh man
i love that line your hero getting ready
to happen yeah i like it it's good hold
on kelly he's gonna pick up and get that
for you kiddo this is the ramsey show
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality
best-selling author is my co-host today
he will be in dallas this wednesday
signing books at the barnes and noble on
beltline road prestonwood town center
they'll be there wednesday at six
o'clock make sure you make plans to come
out there was over a hundred folks
showed up for the book signing the other
day in phoenix arizona pretty incredible
line and i got to he got to meet all of
them hang out it's kind of fun doing
those hey man it got chaotic we were
laughing and people we had a good time
so come on out ready to have some fun
yeah it was a good time you'll be
talking a little bit answering questions
signing books whatever we need to do the
new book is own your past change your
future it's only twenty dollars at
ramseysolutions.com
you can check it out there it's uh not
for people healing from a traumatic
experience it's for practical steps for
everyone in every walk of life own your
past change your future everyone needs
to read this book
it'll help you get back on center and
help you head out in the right direction
it's pretty incredible so you get to
meet dr john baloney in person in dallas
wednesday this coming wednesday at six
o'clock barnes and noble preston wood
town center beltline road dallas texas
do not
miss this taylor is with us in sioux
falls south dakota hi taylor welcome to
the ramsey show
hey guys how are you better than we
deserve what's up
well um we'll dive right in here so
about a year ago or so i i
bought a new building and we moved my
business down to this building and we
were we basically bootstrapped the whole
thing like we did all the remodel on it
ourselves and we did all sorts of cool
stuff and
made it great and kind of at the end of
the fall kind of early winter um uh one
of our vendors that we deal with had a
i don't want to call it like a retreat
kind of deal so it's kind of a gift i uh
one of my one of my employees who hasn't
really done much he helped a lot but he
didn't he hasn't really like
been anywhere in the
in the country i said hey
um there's a mountain bike thing down
here and um it's just something that you
want to do like i'd be happy to send you
it'd be a good learning experience so
he's very great
so he went down there and unfortunately
uh he got into a bicycle accident
um and i get a call you know a day after
he's down there and he's in the hospital
and he broke a
couple broken bones and a few other
things um and initially i wasn't super
concerned because i was like this is
going to be an unfortunate work you know
workers comp thing that we're going to
have to deal with and um what we'll make
it through well uh by the time i call my
insurance the the left hook to the face
was when we moved our building they
quote unquote forgot to renew our
workers comp insurance
um and so and i was like great well then
come to find out that he also doesn't
have health insurance so now um what
i've done in the last i've been
basically got hit with fifty four
thousand 000
of medical bills
um i have paid personally about
36 000 of that
um
and i don't know i mean basically
was that the right call or what would
you guys have done in that situation
there's about 18 000 left to pay
it's tough and i just don't know if if i
made the right call or not
wow
yeah okay he was on a
recreational thing on his own or was it
like a leadership that you bought and
gave it to him as a gift
okay yeah so so it so workers wouldn't
have covered it anyway
okay if i give my one of my team members
a gift to go ride on a boat and the boat
i don't know he gets hurt on the boat
that's not where he's not working
he's playing was it a leadership retreat
of some sort
you know it so so we're a bike shop and
then the company had like a yeah kind of
like a i guess like it's like a retailer
retreat yeah but did you send the whole
company down there and he got hurt or
you just gave him this as a gift
no they allowed one employee so i sent
him as one employee
i don't think this is going to be
covered under workers comp even if you
had it but i'm not a you know you'd have
to ask an attorney
either way so if i've got an employee
that doesn't have health insurance
and um i want to help them
because they were doing something that i
gave them and they got hurt so i would
feel
even if i'm not legally obligated i'd
feel like i wanted to help yeah i
probably would have done what you've
done
the only thing i would have done
differently is i would have called every
one of these
medical providers and said hey this is
not insurance covered it's me paying it
out of pocket so
what's the discount for cash and for the
uninsured person
because usually it's happening right
yeah so we did that and that was it was
about 30 reduction okay um
and then that got it down to 51.
yeah this guy got tore
yeah
up
wasn't good yeah it was not not good
luckily i mean fortunately he's you know
it's not like brain related or anything
like that yeah what do you make of you
uh the business or me personally well
the business is you personally dude
yeah uh i mean i have a combined income
with my wife yeah okay so what do you
what's your household income
it's about 250k okay i would pay it yeah
okay
so get it discounted as far as you can
and pay it you don't have a i don't
think you have a legal obligation
um but i would do it just to help
somebody that i love and that i was
trying to do something nice for and it
got screwed up
okay we rented out an ice rink one time
for a bunch of employees and we were
down there skating and shooting hockey
pucks and i hit one of my guys in the
face i paid for all of it i paid for
every bit of it
it was awful it was horrible it was one
of the worst stories ever on dave i
didn't mean to i shot the puck and he
fell just as i shot it and hit him right
in the face
and so i ended up paying i ended up
paying for all of his nose to get fixed
and all this it was bad so but it was
you know
you know he fell i didn't hit him so
taylor i'm gonna ask dave a question and
this is for you but this is just me
talking to my buddy here um asking a
little more wisdom and dave this comes
from me
probably spending too long working with
lawyers my whole career
if i'm gonna write somebody a check even
out of like hey man i i've i want to
help you out here would it be wise to
say i'm going to cover these medical
bills and then we're going to be square
the two of us because i wouldn't want to
have happiness 10 years from now
he comes back and says you owe him lost
wages or something yeah or my hip hurts
because of my knee thing you know like
that you're i'm doing this as a favor
yeah you might want to get a release
signed it just says i'm going to cover
all this because i love you and you're
not going to come back and get me but
due to no obligation other than i just
want to help yeah yeah
we're not admitting fault here or
whatever the legal mumbo jumbo is that's
probably a good point john
you know but uh i actually didn't get
that when i smashed the guy's face he
was just kind and loved yeah he just was
terrified he came by and visited the
other day he works in another city now
and he's a wonderful guy he's got a
great nose now
and so
let's be honest you hit him at a direct
right angle no that thing chipped off
completely released that shot and i
played hockey in college man i released
that it was so bloody it was so bad i
felt so bad but yeah it was awful i mean
that's one of many times that um i mean
we've had people
odds and ends like that where we're
technically not probably liable because
when you're playing on an ice rink
that's not work so i don't think workers
comp covers that i didn't require them
to be there as a part of work we were
out there goofing off would they have
some
no
because of me shooting a buck no i don't
think so
i don't think so they probably got big
signs up this says something like stupid
people beware don't stand in front of
flying don't stand in front of dave when
he releases a shot but oh my god but
yeah the yeah i mean stuff like that has
happened around here and we've just
covered it yeah when in doubt
do the right now what our hr manual says
is treat other people like you won't be
treated yeah
that's what it says the golden rule what
jesus said yeah treat other people like
i want to be treated so if i made 250 if
you know if i make nothing and i got no
insurance and i'm an hourly worker and
my boss makes 250 000 a year and he
picks up my medical bills that feels a
lot like jesus to me yeah
but it doesn't it's not a requirement
and you're not
a sinner if you don't do it right but
it's just a thing of you know it just
feels very compassionate very big
very noble
and that's the kind of guy this guy is
that just called i mean no that's a good
man right there yeah he just cares and
yeah he's just loving his people
taylor's a good guy yeah you know and
that's there's more employers out there
like that by the way than there are that
way more like cut everybody's throat
especially small business people they're
always like that they just take care of
my people man it's so good and it's just
that's way most people act out here in
the real world now they're not on the
news but that's why they're not on the
news this is the ramsey show
[Music]
uh
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit chministries.org budget don't
worry it's worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage is
bridget hi bridget how are you hi how
are you dave better than i deserve
welcome where do you live i live in
michigan what part uh north of ann arbor
a town called brighton oh yeah very nice
welcome to nashville good to have you
and all the way here to do a debt-free
scream how much have you paid off 111
926 dollars way to go and how long did
that take about 20 months dave good for
you and your range of income during that
time started about 150 000 and at the
peak with a promotion and all of my side
hustles got up to about 250 000. wow
what do you do for a living i lead a
team of analytics consultants and data
scientists for a media company whoo yeah
yeah fun stuff game on i don't even know
what you just said
actually i do because i pay a couple of
them but it's really scary but yeah
yeah way to go a couple of them work
here on the team believe it or not but
that's uh data scientist is a big deal
right now so uh
what were the how many side hustles and
what was the best one
so
i had
three side hustles uh one was
delivering groceries i think that was
the best one that was the most fun
you can set your own schedule
and i was really helping people because
i started doing it during covid
i also took on teaching
data science and visualization online
for university of chicago that had to
pay better than delivering groceries uh
no no not really actually john knows
uh yeah like instructor uh for
professional development so i'm still
doing that but for university that means
you're pretty good at what you do
exactly yeah i mean that's the top of
the top of the top that's incredible
yeah so that's that's been really fun
and i also teach yoga which is a big
part of this story too if you make more
teaching yoga than you do data scientist
stuff i'm gonna die right now i'm just
gonna quit no i don't i don't
all right wow very cool all right so you
told us when we met earlier just to say
high five real quick you said you're not
gonna believe my story so
bring it
so all of that that was from running a
business i
uh in 2014
john you would appreciate this
i lost my father and went through a
divorce and decided to make a really big
decision and open a yoga studio right
during a time of a lot of trauma that's
not the right time to to make that kind
of decision and
thankfully i kept my data science job
and it was it's a hard business to run
and it lost a lot of money over the
years like
30 grand a year in the beginning and
then i got it down to maybe losing like
10 000 a year in the in the final year i
ran it i sold it right before covid wow
but all of that debt was was from
running that business and trying to just
like
move things around right so i had a
business loan over here and maybe i
would pay it with a credit card and
trying to make payroll and it was it was
a lot of stress and it basically took
all of my income away from my you know
my regular job to keep that
thing running wow
you are something else i'm so proud of
you thank you wow to myself so you turn
the key on that walk away sell it and
then covet hitch you got to feel like a
genius i did yeah
[Laughter]
i did my timing there's a chain
pickleball i i sold it december of 2019.
wow
look at you that's amazing
uh that's that's
very well done very well done okay so
then
after all of that we go into covid and
you've got this debt piled up and then
what happened i got really scared dave
you know it everything kind of shut down
i had a really good job but i sat down
and listed all the debt because i think
for five years i was just sort of
pushing it around and not really paying
attention to
what the total was and when i sat down
and did that in march of 2020
i said you know something's got to give
here something has to change so that's
when i went out and got the extra jobs
and
got on a really tight budget and then
the world shuts down right
scary upon scary right yep how did you
how did you find our crazy gang
you know i was my friends were asking me
that on the way over here and i think i
was just doing some googling and and
found you i just started listening to
the podcast obsessively walking around
in my neighborhood during covid walking
the dogs just listening to the stories
and there were a few stories that had
almost the same exact amount of debt
that i had like almost to the dollar
and it just was so inspiring to say if
this person can do that
maybe i could do that right and then i
had a a white board in my office and i
just started coloring in the bars and
more and more bars and then i was like
wow i can do this actually and
then a promotion came at work and just
everything kind of started to snowball
as as you call it um and paying paying
that stuff off and i did it and here i
am you did it and here i am i love it
and all of that in under two years i
mean just over a year and a half you
knock it out pretty amazing at one of
the weirdest year and a half's in the
history of the world i mean oh my gosh i
went after it you did i did
she ain't kidding you can see it in her
eyes that's great i love it
all right what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is
a budget and also just knowing knowing
where you're at financially right like
for me it was that first step of sitting
down and saying this is it this is all
the debt time to time to pay attention
to it and then set that budget
so how intense with all the side hustles
was the work because you go from 150
up to 250. yeah
you were working your butt off i was
delivering groceries every night and and
on weekends and
um you know doing that i just started
the the uchicago stuff uh probably about
six months into the journey
and then when the world started opening
back up i started teaching yoga again
but yeah i was working all the time dude
all the time have you let some of the
air out of some of those side hustles
yes yes a little bit i'm not delivering
the groceries anymore which every once
in a while go take an order and uh it's
still fun but uh it's it's a nice thing
to be able to fall back on as well like
if you're gonna save for something
i drive a car that has 275 000 miles on
it so at some point soon i'm going to
need to uh put some money towards a new
car so that's that's where i'll go hey
bridgette yeah you're dead free and you
make 150 000 you're going to be okay
you don't have to deliver groceries
anymore that's what he says all the time
you're gonna be okay you did it you're
gonna be all right you can also pay for
your own stretchy classes and you don't
even have to work there anymore so good
that's so good yeah let them pay you i'm
good with that yeah you're gonna do it
anyway i mean
keep the university chicago job i'm
jealous that's awesome yeah it's fun
it's all fun good for you proud of you
it's incredibly very well done okay when
you look back on this what was the
moment in the middle of the 20 months
where you just were sh terrified and
didn't know if you could make it where
was that one time where you went uh
probably the summer of 2020 so maybe
three to four months into it at my
company
we were doing pay cuts and furloughs and
i thought there was a good chance that i
i might not be working anymore there
anymore not not by my choice that was
the most terrifying moment
and um i ended up getting promoted a
little short time after that so it
worked out well but it was it was scary
right in the in the height of covet yeah
that was a really high stress time yes
really crazy
yeah the uh amazing amazing well
congratulations we are very proud of you
you're an amazing woman thank you very
very well done
very cool all right we've got a copy of
baby steps millionaires for you how
ordinary people build extraordinary
wealth how you can too copy the total
money makeover for you to give away and
stir up a ruckus with one of your
buddies somewhere very cool stuff you're
you're fun bridget thank you so so much
for making the trip all the way to
nashville to do your debt free scream uh
this girl getting after it right here i
mean she was getting it this is great
she's amazing 112 000 dollars paid off
in 20 months making 150 to 250 oh three
side hustles count it down let's hear a
debt free scream three
two
one i'm debt free
[Music]
wow
and now
she's one of those stories someone else
is watching today this is the ramsay
shot
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host
today he'll be signing books in dallas
his new book own your past change your
future
um
is all about understanding the stories
of your past and um
putting them in context so that the
story of your future makes sense
and
it's powerful
and every one of us has something that
we need to own
in our past
so that
we can change our future and you have to
walk this through you have to decide it
he'll be signing these books in dallas
texas on wednesday night this wednesday
april the 27th at 6 p.m prestonwood town
center on beltline road is be sure and
come out there's probably going to be
100 200 people out there he'll be
talking for a few minutes answering
questions
and um so forth so john it's been at
least
six to nine months since i've really
pissed somebody off about covid
so um i'm way over
i'm way overdue oh good but um i'll
tread as gently as i can uh we're
talking at the break and we're talking
about bridgette and
the
what was the low point for her was the
summer of 2020 when her company's laying
people off being furloughed she didn't
know if she's going to lose her 100 plus
thousand dollar a year job instead she
ends up getting a promotion so it nets
out
we've got
this company with 1200 team members the
leadership team here scratching and
clawing and entire segments of our
revenue just evaporated and we've got
the responsibility to these 1200
families that we promised them we were
going to pay them and the stress of our
on our leadership team of carrying that
um
and uh my friend craig groschel just did
a podcast um a leader she does a
leadership podcast i was on it a little
while back i'm getting ready to be on
another one but he just did want to
listen to this week he talked about how
people were depleted
and that we need to
as we lead out of
this pandemic we need to be replenished
we need to be refilled
filled back up our gas tank is empty the
gr gears are grinding there's no oil in
the crank case there's no lubricant in
our lives anymore we got nothing left
and in the middle of that the economy
goes bonkers
with inflation and with job
opportunities there's labor wars so
people are fighting over you to pay you
more but they want to work you more
than you've ever worked in your life in
order for to get that pay
and so we went from
scared to death trapped at home
sitting on zero
to
220 miles an hour
with no lubrication in the engine that's
right and so we've got a whole bunch of
people out there that are completely
depleted
and um
they're gonna smoke
it's gonna the engine's gonna smoke it's
gonna blow yeah and if you if you back
out and say you know our friend jacob
talks about this there's been no
ownership of
the good or the bad
you can't
you have to acknowledge what happened to
you negatively yeah it became
politicized as to whether they were
right or not to do the quarantine right
or not to do so
right or not to make me clean the office
of 60 000 bucks a swipe by the cdc
guidelines and then they come out later
and say it doesn't help at all right
after i spent 250 thousand dollars
cleaning the freaking office of people
back at work and people still is sending
us hate mail and bomb threats that's
right in the building it's because we
dared to be at work when you when you
experience a collective trauma somebody
has to stop
everybody and say well before we race
off and before we move on before we
start print money and pretend this never
happened which is what we've done right
and bridget talked about she went
through a divorce she had some loss and
so she's just i'm just going to open a
yoga studio yeah right because i'm just
going to pretend this and then that ends
in ash and all of us who have launched
out of the last six months trying to
pretend the last two years never
happened and not collectively grieve
what we lost we a million people and we
lost people are dead our friends our
family members have passed away we've
looked back and said we shouldn't have
done it like this will someone just say
that please and we should have been all
that has to ha you have to process that
together you have to otherwise you take
off you got no i love that you said
there's no oil in the in the in the
engine it'll go for another 150 miles
200 miles and you're gonna be all the
people can be straight on the side of
the road man
i hate it own it man stop and own what
happened so that you can move forward
yeah well societally we're not gonna get
anyone to own it at leadership because
we don't have any leaders it's so
embarrassing man and so embarrassing
societally they're not gonna own it what
what jaco says that a good leader should
do is not gonna happen so given that
that's not gonna happen um each of us as
individuals have got to own
our part of it and go oh wait a minute
that did happen to me
that did hurt
i was
terrorized
by my own government
by people who disagreed with me yeah and
if you believed one thing the other side
terrorized you it didn't matter what it
was you believed right because the
source of truth was no longer there was
no source of truth
anybody that claimed to be the source of
truth was laughed at um because
uh because they weren't the source of
truth
you know uh e.g fauci you know and so uh
you know has become a laughing you know
has become a laughing stock
of the whole thing he's like the he was
like the head of the circus yeah you
know and so
but nobody's coming back and going look
he was just wrong yeah it's two million
people he never slayed he never came up
and said hey last three months i said
this i was inaccurate we got new data
it's time to do this now no that never
happened never once and if if if i could
pass along one piece of information
after working with hurting people for so
many years and you too
if you're in leadership and you head
down a road and you realize this isn't
the right road just stop and turn back
to tell the folks keep your we're on the
wrong road keep your reverse gear in
good working order
that's such a gift to everybody and it's
not a matter of of weakness or failure
it's a matter of strength right just to
say hey we got new data and it's time to
do this now and i had said this let's
but all of us i think you're right we
can talk about that all day
what i have to do is look in the mirror
me and my wife have had to have you you
acknowledge we're not gonna fix those
goobers okay but what you and i do need
to you address for the listener right
this second is
that
um you can't go on as if nothing
happened that's right because it did
denial is not a river in egypt that's
right it's a real thing
and so you have got to
uh say this happened
i i
face stuff i've never faced before i've
felt things i never felt before i may
have even done things or done before and
and
uh
i'm
i'm not going to go back to the way it
was
until i put some gas back in my tank and
then it'll never really be back the way
i got to build something new that's
right i'm going to lead not
as if nothing happened i'm going to lead
out of this i'm going to leave my life
and you are in control of leading your
life if you're listening to us right now
so lead your own life you know leading
your life is you are the leader
and so you have to use critical thinking
skills you have to say
emotionally this hurt physically i was
scared for my life
um there was you know trauma with that
and the real world is that that really
happened now is it debilitating for the
rest of your life does it have to become
the defining thing for your life
absolutely not it shouldn't be but if
you pretend like it didn't happen you're
going to turn to ash
everything around you will turn ashes
right one of the most
common questions i get is where do i
start and i would say 95 of the time
there's a relationship or two that was
significant to you that went away over
the last couple of years either they
said something you said something you
felt the way they felt the way and
that's where i would start i would look
over the course of the relationships
that i burned or lost or got frustrated
with over the last couple of years and
say is there some people there i need to
call and say dude 30 years isn't worth
this over the last two years if let's is
there a conversation i need to have with
my spouse and say hey man we got
sideways the last two years and i just
put some stuff in in the drawer we need
to just have a chit chat but are there
relationships that i can begin to heal
and maybe there aren't maybe i need to
then replace those that are gone yeah or
it might just be you say okay i don't
respect that person that's right so
we've moved on but i've got to replace
those with other people in my life right
yeah this person uh i
i saw new colors and i saw things about
them that i don't want to i don't want
to be around that's right but i can't i
can't use that as an excuse to do life
by myself anymore right i got to go find
new people that doesn't give you excuse
to not deal with you that's right the
book is own your past change your future
it will do that yeah if you get a copy
of it and read it i promise you and
you've got to put some gas back in your
tank folks you've got to replenish
because if you're walking around in the
human race right now the last two years
has depleted you
and so you must fill that back up in
order to function at full
game on capacity
this is the ramsey shaft
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us america dr john deloney
ramsey personality is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
we'll take calls from you because we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create real
relationships by the way that's done in
the middle of a fake world so there you
go it's gods and grandma's ways of
living your life
again free call triple eight eight two
five five two two five devon is with us
in montana hi devon welcome to the
ramsay show
hi dave hi doctor john thank you guys
for taking my call
how are you today better than we deserve
what's up
uh so
back in
early 2018 my grandparents had run into
some money and they decided to give it
to
a lot of the grandkids
i was given
three thousand dollars but with the
uh
attached with it he wanted it to be used
but my grandpa wanted it to be both my
grandparents
uh for education or investment only
i chose to invest it in some etfs
which have grown about 50
since then
um
but so my wife and i we have started our
debt-free journey at the beginning of
this month and we're already in baby
step two
um and
i'm wondering if i should use this money
towards paying off the debt
but i'm kind of torn because
i feel like i'd be betraying
the reason that i was given this money
for
so i was curious on your opinion about
it
when you get out of debt
what is your plan for money
uh
well our first plan is obviously to
build a uh emergency fund three to six
months then what is your plan for money
um
well i
would like to eventually start a family
with my wife
and move to a larger house
okay you're gonna follow the baby steps
and start investing 15 of your income
into retirement
yes
and then when you're 100 debt free
you're going to follow what we've been
teaching around here which is
unbelievable generosity
and continuing to invest
okay so are you not investing the money
then
well
you're going around the barn to get
there but my point is your most powerful
wealth building tool is not your
grandfather's gift it is your income and
by getting out of debt you're going to
honor your grandfather's wishes because
you're going to be an investor what your
grandfather didn't want you to do is go
buy something stupid
right yeah and that's why it came with
that stipulation yeah and what did he
how long did he expect you to invest
this for
um
you know he didn't really say yeah to
never be used for anything ever to never
use it when you never use it ever when
you need it for anything
to buy a house to do anything smart with
he was just trying to keep you from
doing some stupid butt something with it
my granddad passed away several years
ago but i guarantee you this he's a
world war ii vet he was an engineer he
was meticulous and if i had come to him
and said hey i invested a gift you gave
me for x number of years it's grown to
this and i'd like to use it to become
debt free so that i can invest more so
that i can build wealth he would have
hugged me
right
your grandpa would too dude yeah is your
grandpa gone
no he's still around okay all right
are we putting words in his mouth or not
uh
no
yeah
so i mean
listen if you want to take the money out
and tr and and cruise around the world
and end up 25 years old and broke later
i'm not going to tell you to do that and
because your grandfather would ring your
neck and so would i okay but that's not
what we're discussing here we're talking
about using the money to further your
wealth building
so that you can enjoy your life be
outrageously generous and change your
family tree which was ultimately his
intent he was just trying to keep you
from doing something dumb
and so but i mean if you just go up and
go hey i paid off all my debt and he
thinks you're going to go right back in
debt he's going to think that was dumb
right
so if you want to have a conversation
with him it wouldn't be too bad
how much debt do you have
uh so we have about uh forty thousand
dollars in debt and what is this three
thousand grown to
it's grown to about 4 500.
okay okay
so you're not talking about cashing out
a 50 000 plan either and paying off 50
000 worth of debt i mean you're talking
about a small amount
yeah just to kind of take a chunk out of
it
so um you know i i don't know how he'll
react i have no idea but i'm guessing
this is guy's just a common sense guy
and he just didn't want you to do
something stupid you're not doing
something he very much is as long as you
follow through on this i think it's in
the spirit of the gift
if you follow through and just
and you're not consuming the money
irresponsibly instead you're using the
money to invest to ultimately become a
better investor but if you don't follow
through on it if you pay off the credit
cards and then you turn around and run
them back up again i mean he's going to
box your ears and so will i
and
deservedly so right yeah or maybe maybe
you make this the last 45 you pay off
not the first 45
and it can be the you know the little
light here at the end of the tunnel yeah
but i don't know it's okay to have a
discussion with him about it um
but um it's not his money anymore by the
way yeah he gave that he gave uh he
you're trying to be kind by honoring his
intentions and that's good and i
appreciate the honor that you have in
that uh but you're under no obligation
you do whatever you want to do with it i
mean you can go blow it i wouldn't
recommend that but because i think you'd
feel bad for the rest of your life about
it so i inherited five thousand dollars
from my grandmother
when she passed away years and years and
years and years ago she had eight
bazillion grandkids and they sold the
big farm and that's we each got like
five forty eight hundred bucks or
something
and uh i have no idea where it went
no i do and so you don't want to live
with that taste in your mouth yeah the
rest of your life because i have to sit
here and say that out loud because
that's what really happened yeah
and so you know in this case you know
exactly what happened but the trick is
that makes this an honorable move
if you used it to pay off the debt is to
follow all the way through and the net
result is you're investing more
and so but if if something short of that
happens then you've not honored him and
that's not what we would advise you to
do then so
good question thank you for joining us
it's a powerful thing on
honor yeah it's hard
honor is a good thing yeah and it's um
it's in short supply
so when you can find
a young guy like that particularly that
is um
concerned about honor that's a good
thing it's the best thing yeah if you if
you say i'm a person who is honorable it
will frame a lot of your daily actions
and choices yeah it's a there's a beauty
to it oh yeah there's a beauty to it
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
dr john dolone ramsay personality
best-selling author host of the dr john
dolone show is my co-host today you can
purchase his new book own your past
change your future it's now available
everyone needs to read it you can get it
anywhere great books are sold including
ramsey solutions.com or if you happen to
be in dallas you can see him in person
he'll be signing books talking and
answering questions
and um all this wednesday april the 27th
at 6 00 p.m
at the barnes and noble at prestonwood
town center on beltline road that's a
great bookstore i've signed books in
there myself
good folks there and you good folks at
dallas turnout let's have a bunch of
folks there see if you can beat phoenix
phoenix had a little over a hundred
folks there so we're expecting a hundred
and two hundred there and down and it's
a party so everybody come it's gonna be
a blast
yeah all right
i love it hey let me ask you a question
when you think of a millionaire what
kind of job do you picture them having
some kind of high-powered executive like
a vp or a ceo nope only 15 percent of
millionaires actually have jobs like
that the reality is the top five careers
for millionaires in america are engineer
accountant teacher manager and attorney
that is one of the many surprising
things our team found when we conducted
the largest study of millionaires ever
done we talked to over 10
000
millionaires our study made it clear
that to become a millionaire you've got
to invest
steadily
and wisely
calmly
it's a big part of getting
good investing advice
you need to work with an investing pro
that can walk with you talk you off the
ledge
teach you
teach you
teach you
about the options you choose
our team recommends trustworthy
vetted vetted investing pros from all
over the country we call them smart
vester pros to get in touch with one of
our smartvestor pros in your area go to
ramseysolutions.com smart vester and you
can start building wealth today ramsey
solutions dot com slash smart vester
blinds.com gives us our question of the
day they're the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings free
samples free shipping and new promos all
the time you'll save even more if you
use the promo code ramsay you'll get the
best possible deal
all right today's question comes from
christina in houston christina writes my
younger sister is 23 and works a
part-time job at a mall
she's a college dropout refuses to get a
full-time job and has a different dream
job every day that she won't take any
action on she lives with our parents
pays no bills and has maxed out credit
cards when i mention getting a full-time
job while creating an action plan for
her current dream she says there's no
time to work a full-time job cook work
out hang out with her boyfriend and do
these small steps towards her dream
she has good intentions but often gets
crippled at the overwhelming thought of
juggling everything
my parents tend to be enablers because
they don't want to make her mad and
pushing her in the wrong direction
how can i help her have the life that
she
wants
who unfortunately older sister i don't
believe can because she continues your
younger sister continues to have parents
that are funding and supporting and
enabling this life
reminds me of our friend
henry cloud says sounds like she needs
to get some problems she needs to get
some challenges she doesn't have enough
problems her parents need to have her
out she doesn't have any bills she
doesn't have any she is not dealing with
reality here how can you help her have
the life she wants talk your parents
into kicking her out that's right
setting some boundaries
or you start paying rent in four months
and this is what that's going to look
like yeah
because this girl is operating on a 13
year old
emotional level it's not a 23 year old
emotional level
she's a little girl that wants to do
whatever she wants and she's got
princess itis and mama needs to kick her
out listen baby
an eagle that doesn't leave the nest is
eventually known as a turkey
it's a problem
that may be the most tennessee thing
i've ever heard you say
well i mean i like it though i like it
yeah you gotta go man you gotta you
gotta fly you do not emotionally develop
the final steps of your
emotional development into adulthood
while living under your parents roof
that's right
not in america
now there's other cultures where that's
more standardized and there's a
different process but the typical anglo
american idea and it's not to be cold
and it's not to be mean or it's not to
be any of that but you just when you pay
your own light bill when there's no milk
in the refrigerator unless you get your
butt up off the couch go to the grocery
store and buy some milk with your money
and put it in the refrigerator something
happens to you developmentally it's
called responsibility and moms and dads
if you do not instill this in your kids
you are stealing from them you are
robbing from your kids if you don't
encourage them not encourage them
through well you know it'd be good but
require them to have responsibilities to
do hard things to get jobs to
participate around the of the in the
function of your home
it it gives them strength
to go do life
it's amazing how often that doesn't
happen we took our first kid to college
um
we spent the whole day moving her in
and um it was a two and a half hour
drive
and uh of course it's my oldest since my
daughter
and so we cried
almost halfway home about an hour 15
minutes yeah
and by the time we got here the sun had
come out we're smiling life is good we
took the second one to college rachel
um dropped her off in the dorm we cried
one exit
nothing a dairy queen couldn't fix and
then we got to the third one and we said
college is that way
exactly
and we just helped him pack the truck
and he left that's right
have a great weekend man so because uh
we were looking forward to empty nesting
your mom and dad christina need to look
forward to empty nesting
[Laughter]
we love it
it's awesome
yeah so um
yeah it's the natural evolution of life
and it is a
that
my point of telling that story on myself
is to tell you the truth the truth is
that change
from raising kids to releasing them is a
painful change
it's brutal it's hard brutal and your
mom and dad are being wusses
by not turning their sh your dog your
little sister is their security blanket
they don't want to face their life when
she's gone right and so and they're
they're they're couching all of this and
being nice to her and that's absolute
bull they're selfish they need to
release her that that that may be the
best word they're selfish like they are
choosing their momentary
um she's their security block that's
right she's a the little [ __ ] i don't
want this to be over right that's it and
it's not over it's just it's different
that's right it's just different yeah
and so and let me tell you the different
part is if she gets out there and
marries the boyfriend has babies that's
the awesome part so let's do it yeah
grandbabies i mean they're awesome i
don't know how great grandbabies are
going to be out have been nicer to their
parents
so i mean it's just you know
you you there there's a lot of that a
lot of stuff going on here so bottom
line is christina you really can't help
her john's right the only thing the
biggest help you could do is talk your
parents into releasing her
if you could convince your parents that
they're harming her
not blessing her which is actually the
truth then you probably have done your
job for the day and by the way christina
um when when little sister finds out you
have this conversation she's going to be
all mad at you and that's part of being
a sister wells that's part of love in
her
oh wellesley part of loving her didn't
affect you one way or the other it's all
for her
her good
good luck with that open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five aaron is in utah i am a homemaker
we have children and more to come is it
worth it to purchase life insurance for
just my husband as a sole provider or
should we also purchase life insurance
for me
although i do not bring in an income
no but you bring in a ton of
service
let your husband be without you and he
will discover what mary poppins actually
costs
she's somewhere around forty to fifty
thousand dollars a year right now
if you wanted uh the parrot head
umbrella and the whole deal so um
yeah the you know the
chief cook and bottle washer the tudor
the nanny and the delivery service
uh that delivers them all over town for
their various activities and processes
so uh yeah my stay-at-home moms should
have
between 300 and 500 000 on them if you
have small children at home
[Music]
because if something happens to you your
husband is going to lose a large portion
of his income because he has to come
home and take care of his family because
he can't afford the help
that you are now currently the economic
value that you are bringing to the
household
that's just a true fact that's not just
a stand for stay-at-home moms but it's a
fact there's an economic value that's
forty to fifty thousand dollars a year
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage matthew and jordan are
with us hey guys how are you hey we're
great welcome so good to have you guys
where do you guys live
tucson arizona cool good to have you how
much debt have you paid off uh we paid
off 65
464 dollars and 14 cents love it wow how
long did this account right it took us
26 months good and your range of income
during that time so we started at 99 and
then at the end with all our side
hustles we finished at 127. excellent
very cool what kind of side hustles did
you do uh so i took up tutoring and uh
that was
tutoring on what english writing
okay uh helping college students with
essays what did that pay
um so i charged thirty five dollars an
hour so 45 an hour nice yeah so i'm
actually taking that more full time here
after the honeymoon is over so i'm
really excited for it thank you because
college students writing essays is not a
pretty picture oh no it's not
i'm so grateful you're in the universe
should not have been reading my old
papers listen
just leave them a lot leave me alone
listen don't make it good for you don't
make this personal okay cool and jordan
uh matthew i'm sorry what do you do for
a living so um i'm an aircraft mechanic
for the air force and uh i also for my
side hustle it's not much of a hustle
but i also coach high school swim oh so
for my local high school all right cool
so when you're an air force or mckenna
does that mean you're in the air force
it's a bit of both so i'm an air force
reservist and then i'm a federal
civilian during the week so i work on
the same planes with the same people
same uniform it's just i get paid
differently depending on the status
gotcha okay cool very cool great careers
man this is awesome what kind of debt
was this
what wasn't the debt um so i had 300 on
my iphone 9 000 on my car
uh 21 000 off for student loans for me
and then his truck was 31 000. oh yeah
that was a trip to deserve island before
we started the ramsay plans so
a trip to what island deserve i deserve
oh i deserve island okay yeah and then 3
800 on a credit card yeah it it's it's
true that it is an island though yeah
was it listed
no it was it was uh actually rather uh
it wasn't as fancy as i could have gone
so
you thought you were did you were
playing it safe right yeah did you sell
it or pay it off no i want to paint it
off what is it so it's just a ram 1500
yeah well i've had a 93 jeep wrangler
for most of my driving uh
life and i was always in the shop so my
boss was like please stop calling in for
your broken down car and get a new car
please oh whoa
yeah i'll be happy to do that when you
pay the freaking payments you can give
me my financial advice okay wow look at
you guys okay so you said honeymoon how
long have you been married uh six months
we also cashflowed our wedding during
so you started this track on two side
tracks and then you joined it in the
middle and finished it correct yeah very
cool so tell us the story what happened
what got you started well the the
biggest thing is um my mom has always
followed the ramsey plan and uh was
motivating me to it but i wasn't fully
involved so you're a financial piece
baby that went and bought a new truck
yeah yeah yeah okay mama gotta get mom
jacked up oh yeah
you know i'm a dummy a little bit you
know so i'll jack her up man i'm telling
you she's ready yeah so
um i had the financial piece videos and
we were trying to watch them but we
weren't getting into them sort of thing
and they were on dvd and then uh when i
proposed my mom as a gift got us vip
tickets to one of their uh live events
one of your guys's live events with uh
anthony o'neil and uh chris hogan when
we visited phoenix oh yeah and that spun
her up real hard and i'm just like okay
well yep okay we'll we'll do this that's
fine now i got women on both sides of me
coming at me yeah you ain't got a chance
buddy yeah
so
that was that was a lot of fun and um
like
the only fight throughout the entire
thing was at the very beginning of why
are we planning a month budget after
we've already went through the half the
month because that was the live event
was in the middle of the month oh yeah
so we were like well we already spent
most of our money for this month we had
14 left for groceries for the rest of
the month whoa
so we're buying trash bags and stuffer
grilled cheese sandwiches and that's
what we're going to have for the next
two weeks
lots of sandwiches
wow that's fantastic
you guys are fun
congratulations thanks wow i bet your
mom is jumping up and down all kidding
aside i don't think she's happy
definitely yeah very cool how does it
feel
it was a little unreal at first yes kind
of uh we actually oh we were able to pay
everything off just a little ahead
schedule um i was able to
have a
reserve paycheck come in with additional
orders and stuff like that we were able
to kind of put all of that towards it
and uh so we were just like cool we just
hit it and then now what and then just
disappeared from the account we're like
uh
okay is that done then yeah his truck
was the last thing we paid off and we
were you know thinking okay it'll
probably be like
march april and we paid it off before
christmas wow whoa so slam dunk yeah
slam dunk good good for you guys
what what do you tell people now you're
pros what do you tell them the key to
getting out of debt is
you really have to talk about the budget
and give yourself time because like you
said like take three months figure out
the budget we had well me i had so many
subscriptions i forgot i had and they
would hit you know every three months or
yearly and i go oh no and it was just a
scramble to you know reconfigure the
budget
and after that three months it was it
was actually really smooth sailing from
there oh yeah so what kind of
subscriptions did you have that were
just
bone stupid that you you look at and you
go i can't believe i did that
um i had like a meditation subscription
app and i had
you know like i was paying extra for
sephora to get free shipping and
really unnecessary stuff okay that's
really unnecessary all right there you
go good i love it that's good good for
well everybody has them that's why you
know you're not unique in that uh
everybody has done that and that is one
that does sneak up on folks and bust a
budget that's a good point i'm glad you
brought that up very very cool so what
was your biggest disagreement you had
let's see
um i think it was when we were trimming
down the subscriptions of like what
streaming services are we actually going
to go for and
uh what families can we uh um
be able to share accounts with and stuff
like that
to make it
make it all work out so you know we'll
and uh
then it just kind of went to we barely
even used the those streaming apps once
we finally were just working all the
time when we got rid of our dish and
yeah got rid of a bunch of stuff so what
did you fill that time with like doing
crazy things like spending time together
and
going for walks and exercising and
things
yeah we did some of that but honestly
this last year we've been working so
much you know i'd work my 40 hour a week
job and then i'd come home and i tutor
for a couple of hours and he would do
his full-time job and then go coach swim
and then he'd have his reserve weekend
so i'd have weekends to myself and i go
okay i guess i'm gonna tutor some more
and uh you know we we have two dogs so
we find out how much time we how much of
our life we give away to those people on
the screen who don't even know we're
there just outsource it man it's amazing
we give away a ton of our life to those
people
and uh just you know throw a brick
through your tv you get amazing amounts
of time back yes yeah except you don't
even have to break the tv to do it you
just unplug it
well done you guys we're very proud of
you congratulations yeah very cool great
way to start your lives great way to
start your lives all right we have a
copy of baby steps millionaires for you
and how ordinary people built
extraordinary wealth how you can too
that's certainly the next uh chapter in
your story brand new married learned how
to work together got her done man very
very cool also a copy of total money
makeover for you to give away to
somebody maybe you can stir up a ruckus
in their life that'd be a good thing all
right it's matthew and jordan
it's tucson arizona 65 000 paid off in
26 months making 99 to 127. count it
down let's hear a debt free scream
[Applause]
[Music]
that's how you do it right there ladies
and gentlemen love it love it
beautifully done
beautifully done man
what i would give to go back and be able
to start my marriage six months in debt
free
that would be i can't even wrap my head
around how different my life would be in
the positive i was just getting started
going into debt oh me too i was just
digging a hole
oh honey we can make this one way deeper
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture today psalm 27 4 one thing
i ask of the lord this is what i seek
that i may dwell in the house of the
lord all the days of my life
to gaze upon the beauty of the lord
and to seek him in his temple
cory ten boom said when a train goes
through a tunnel and it gets dark you
don't throw away the ticket and jump off
you sit still
and trust the engineer
oh that's classic i love it dr john
deloney ramsey personality is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five dallas texas
mark your calendars he'll be signing
books this coming wednesday the 27th at
6 pm
at the barnes and noble at prestonwood
town center on beltline road make sure
you jump out there in dallas and come
see him it's a great store great
opportunity there'll be a couple hundred
folks probably there and he'll get the
books signed really quick answer
questions for you and i'll be talking as
well you're going to learn a lot aj is
with us aj's in dallas texas hi aj how
are you
i'm better than i deserve sir how are
you doing just the same sir what's up
well there just some background
information i've been listening to you
since i was two and i am 21 about to
turn 22 so cool been a great influence
on my life um thank you
quick question
um
my boss originally
left three weeks ago from my current
position and
we work in escrow and i was supposed to
go to the new company with her but
uh
legal action's been taken and i no
longer have a viable option of going to
a new company
and my current position is kind of whoa
whoa stop stop stop stop stop stop what
are you talking about they stop they put
a cease and desist on her from stealing
their employees
i can either confirm or deny that's what
they told me
um
uh
lawyers for the current company that i'm
working on sir
i don't think they can put a gag on
order on you like that i think they're
trying to scare you
okay have you talked to the new company
yes they said they cannot offer me the
position
due to these legal actions being taken
and
because of that
my current position like i said is
hanging on by a thread so i don't know
if i should be scared
uh all right so
walk me through this for a second
because this is so interesting so okay
so your old boss left promised you a job
at the new place the new place said you
can't come because of legal action and
the place you work for now brought in
their lawyers to meet with you at 21
years old and explain to you you cannot
go to the new place because of the legal
action and you can't say a word to
anybody about any of this
yes that's what i'm under the impression
okay find you another job this week and
leave this place
as fast as possible get away from these
people
ah
yes serious that's
that's what i was thinking um yeah it's
just i mean i have a i have a move soon
i'm moving in my apartment i was a
college student and
i didn't say quit being homeless i said
go find another job yeah
how old are you
21 21 get a return 22.
yeah what do you make
37 800. okay yeah you can find another
job doing that you have a college degree
or not
that's a whole different story sir no i
do not uh do you do some family drama
how long have you been how long have you
been doing this
what now
it's coming up on a year in july okay
you work for a real estate escrow
company that closes real estate sales
yes sir
okay
you can go to if you can't go to work
for the same company that your boss went
to you can go to work for another one
you did not sign a non-compete when you
went to work there i'll guarantee you
you didn't
did you yeah
not that i'm aware of sir no i went
through my paperwork and i didn't see
anything okay so something about the
other guys stealing employees is what
they're trying to shut down
and so uh the poaching of that
uh and and so you can you know if you
don't go to work for another escrow
company i don't care go to work for
freaking uh target or walmart but go get
a job in the next five days and get out
of there these people are not good
people and aj um i'm gonna speak into
you a minute is that okay
yes sir in this one phone call i've
heard you
as a 21 year old
ex express in a couple of different ways
that you're a victim and you're trapped
and you're stuck
and i want to rattle you out of that
you don't you don't have a college
degree because you didn't finish a
college degree you might have had family
drama that contributed but you you
haven't finished a college degree
you're getting either a weird shakedown
that neither dave or i've never heard of
before happening with your job cool i'm
moving on
i want you to have this be a moment
where nobody's gonna own aj and aj's
gonna make some license life decisions
financially you're not gonna owe anybody
any money you may get a job making 50
000 a year if you start looking right
now using that techniques yeah get it
you're not a victim you are a victor go
get them man you know you hear what i'm
saying there's a totally different way
to look at this if you're going to drag
me into your office and scare me with
your lawyers you're going to walk out
the door i don't need this
almost smile on the way out yeah
it's just i think more so the reason i'm
feeling so stressed is because i i have
a fiance
support each other we're
living together and
i'm in a deep hole days
um
because of the family drama i was i
screwed myself over you know i shot
myself in the foot took out loans that i
shouldn't have taken out i
had free tuition but like i said the
family trauma screwed me over
to where i wasn't able to
accept my fafsa and
no it didn't screw you over here you
chose in the middle of the family drama
to make decisions that screwed you over
you screwed you over take ownership of
it man
i i i signed my name on the line dotted
line i totally understand that it's not
the family drama's fault it's your fault
what do you owe man so here's the thing
all this stress that you have on you
goes away
if you find a job making forty thousand
dollars doing something else by the end
of the week and i'll bet you can
actually
would you agree with me that if you find
a job making forty thousand dollars all
this other stuff that's bothering you
the debt the fiance the apartment change
all this stuff it's no longer a worry
because you weren't worried about it
before all this
finding a job making forty thousand
makes all this stress go away does it
not
aj yes sir two degree yes sir two
degrees well to the degree that it did
before your boss left i mean if you were
going to take the job over the other
place all that stuff still would have
been there you still got to change
apartments you're still getting married
you still got debt but that's just part
you got to fight through those things no
matter where you are
but you called us about these
crazy butt people that you work for and
i'd be running out of there like my hair
was on fire man yeah so go get a job as
soon as you get a job walk in and say um
tell your lawyers i said stick it and
take off man i mean you don't have to be
that mean but that's just that's
basically the message you threaten me
with a lawyer i don't work here anymore
that's easy
done
listen i have never tried to keep an
employee by threatening one with a
lawyer that's kind of like that's
probably just not good not good juice
man it's not gonna get not gonna give
them the result that they want because
that just breathes loyalty every time i
just really wanna work so hard for this
company because they threaten me with a
lawyer that's dumber than crap that's
the worst leadership i've heard and i
don't know when
stupid corporate america and then to
bring a 21 year old and just sweat them
out yeah let's let the cause because
we're obviously gonna go out of business
if he leaves
i mean come on
this is just look how big and tough we
are
yeah i'll show you at least if you have
to let's say this let's say you have to
bring the 21 year old in and explain
here here's what's happening yeah here's
the this is you don't need the lawyers
to do you're caught in the middle of a
mess i'm sorry yeah and you're not gonna
be able to take that of the job because
we're not gonna let the guy poach our
company
and so you you are stuck in that regard
you may not want to work here and we're
not mad at you you didn't do anything
but anyway so that's yeah go get another
job aj hold on we're going to give you a
copy of ken coleman's book from paycheck
to purpose and i'll give you a copy of
the assessment to help you do that and
get on his site kingcoleman.com read
everything you can about getting a job
and go get one this week because 40 000
jobs are
a lot easier to be had right now than
they were while back and um you need to
get out of there my friend you need to
get out of there and you own all this
other stuff it didn't happen to you
you're happening to you that puts us
hour the ramsey show in the books we'll
be back with you before you know it in
the meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace christ jesus
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 600-plus radio stations
across the country to find a station
near you go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you